bonjour louis joseph manscour députés
européens sortants et en place encore
jusqu'au 2 février lendemain jusqu'au 2
juillet jusqu'au 2 juillet monsieur leur
secours lendemain d'élections
européennes avec la gueule de bois pour
le militant socialiste que vous êtes aux
gueules de bois c'est beaucoup dire voir
ce qu'on s'y attendait le score fait par
les socialistes
on savait bien que ce serait très
difficile compte tenu de la conjoncture
politique pour nous mais que de bois
parce que il ya une faible participation
chez nous une confirmation d'une percée
de l'extrême droite surtout c'est
surtout de la le fait marquant du faible
participation oui mais quand même c'est
une augmentation de 5 points par rapport
à 2014 donc proposé un progrès un petit
progrès maintenant concernant la place
de trn internationale tant le paysage
politique est français et antillais
surtout domiens ça ne revient très grave
je pensais une longue réflexion qu'il
faut de l'amener pense qu on est passé
en dix ans de 2,01 déposants a
maintenant 25 26 % il ya vraiment un
problème
alors comment vous l'expliquez vous avez
entendu tout à l'heure lors de notre
édition de cette heure ces personnes que
nous avons interrogées du côté de deux
volcans se disant le rassemblement
national l'extrême droite ne sera jamais
au pouvoir c'est une erreur de continuer
à parler comme ça tout à faire je veux
c'est une erreur parce que quand on
regarde bien le paysage politique
français on constate que on a voulu
diaboliser le front national le
rassemblement national
madame le pen depuis de nombreuses
années il faut qu'on arrête
il faut qu'on propose toute une autre
alternative à nos populations
une autre politique en direction des des
gens de condition modeste une politique
sociale et politique du logement
et c'est à ce prix qu'on arrivera à
faire comprendre qu yves on n'a pas
intérêt à voter pour le front national
et pour l'extrême-droite quelle quelle
conclusion quelles leçons tirer de ce
parti de cette élection européenne louis
joseph manscour surtout lorsque nous
sommes ici en martinique qu'elles sont
d'abord on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
d'europe on a parlé surtout des
problèmes
franco français oral bien que le
président de la république et monsieur
mélenchon et des autres ils ont voulu en
quelque sorte en train d'aimer
nationaliser la campagne électorale
toutes les problématiques ont été
évoquées ce sont des politiques
nationales
hélas on n'a pas beaucoup parlé d'europe
la réalité ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a un
parlement européen que toutes tes
promesses qu'on avait fait
il faut une majorité pour pouvoir
appliquer une politique il se trouve
aujourd'hui qui a pas de majorité
toujours au niveau du parlement européen
je dirais même que les socialistes et
sociaux démocrates et le ppe qui avait
une majorité absolue
ils ont perdu leur majorité il faut
vouloir reconstruire de nouvelles
majorités avec des libéraux avec les
socialistes
il faudra trouver des solutions mais le
fait d'avoir des libéraux d'avoir mes
temps 96 cents sièges ou encore les
verts avec 70 sièges
ça ne fait pas une politique ça paie pas
de changer les choses c'est vrai que le
rapport de force a changé mais le
problème la problématique reste est la
même il faut qu'il y ait construit une
majorité pour pouvoir faire avancer les
dossiers des dossiers qui nous
interpellent notamment au niveau des
dirigeants d'outre-mer alors louis
joseph manscour quelle que soit la
formation politique auquel on a à
laquelle on a envie de croire
la caractéristique première de politique
c'est de faire des promesses de vouloir
changer la société de vouloir
l'améliorer et souvent la population se
retrouver au bord du chemin parce
qu'elle dit accrue et puis finalement il
n'a rien vu venir
on a vu cette contestation ces derniers
temps - 4e moi qui ai une petite
expérience de l'entretien elle n'est
peut être pas beaucoup 42 ans
mais je voudrais simplement vous dire
qu'effectivement les populations ou part
de responsabilité on veut faire rêver
les gens il faut faire rêver les gens et
malheureusement les promesses dans la
conjoncture
d'aujourd'hui sont difficiles à tenir
donc on est dans une sorte d'ambiance
parce que d'un côté on souhaite on
espère des choses et de l'autre on n'a
pas la possibilité de le faire donc on
se trouve là ces situations mais je
crois qu'avec des réseaux sociaux avec
tout ce qui se passe maintenant il va
falloir que nous les politiques nous
fassions attention et que nos fans ne
proposions pas nous ne fassions pas de
pros mais ce qui soit irréaliste
alors vous avez certainement remarqué
les espaces ruraux que les listes qui
ont réalisé les meilleurs scores chez
nous n'ont pas véritablement de
structures de véritables relais chez
nous en marche ça frise le néant absolu
le rassemblement national ici comment
dire c'est un peu pathétique ce qui se
passe avec le rassemblement national en
martinique en termes de restructuration
la france est soumise donc pas le
terrain de façon si visible que ça et
pourtant elles sont tentées de ces
formations
oui mais enfin vous savez même s'il n'ya
pas de d'activisme politique entre
guillemets ici mais il faut se dire que
avec les réseaux sociaux avec les médias
on en parle souvent
donc les choses ont beaucoup changé les
gens parlent beaucoup
les la télé écoute beaucoup à dire les
radios ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
reste chez soi assis dans son fauteuil
en arles à l'information
même si parfois l'information est
déformé mais enfin on l'a quand même
mais ça veut dire que c'est beaucoup
plus grave pour les deux grands partis
traditionnels que sont les républicains
et le parti socialiste
vous n'avez pas su faire par rapport aux
autres alors oui c'est vrai que bon les
c'est une erreur je pense de vouloir
dire que les grands partis n'ont plus
leur place
vous savez la constitution française et
des très clair les partis politiques
concourent à l'expression du super scène
par conséquent il faut qu'il y ait des
pans entiers alors bien chiffres des
partis se restructurent il faut qu'il y
ait d'autres ambitions il faut que on
sera beaucoup plus proche de nos
populations
il faut qu'on cesse de faire rêver il
faut bref il faut il faut il faut il
faut faire autre chose pour boire faire
voir alors qu'est ce que vous auriez
envie de proposer à vos collègues
socialistes que ce soit au niveau local
que ce soit au niveau national pour
rebooster ce mouvement et saufs sont
simples
allez sur le tir il faut être proche des
gens il faut pas attendre qu'un jour
vingt jours avant les élections pour
aller saluer allez salut les gens est
allé dans les sous des marchés etc
ah non il faut que ça soit une
quotidienne il faut que on le faisait
avant il ya de cela trente ans même
lorsque même va peut-être eu notre
implication et notre motivation et celle
des militants exclus il y en a
suffisamment aujourd'hui il n'ya pas le
militant il n'y a pas de militants et je
dis je le répète il est à 30 ans je me
souviens bien même en tant que maire et
jallet distribuer des tracts maintenant
on allait faire enfin n'empêche que les
gens il fauda proximité si ce que les
gens demandent donc s'il n'y a pas de
proximité il sera difficile de deux
jeunes n'a peut être pas de la démagogie
comme com com fait le rassemblement
national parce que là c'est du populisme
mais je pense qu'il faut non seulement
être proche des gens
mais aussi appliquer des politiques qui
permettent de résoudre certains des
problèmes auxquels on est confrontés à
ce problème et pour le logement elle
prend de sécurité et les problèmes de
délinquance
il ya des problèmes sociaux via sur rd
nos réponses à ces problématiques
il n'y a pas suffisamment de réponses et
les gens qui critiquent les lecteurs
disant qu'il ne sait pas ce qu'il peut
accélérer se trompe et lecture est très
avertis il connaît bien les choses ils
sont des choses
à preuve quand vous regardez bien qu'on
se retrouve en guadeloupe en martinique
en guyane
on voit même c'est toujours les mêmes
résultats à peu près donc ça prouve que
la population les populations ne sont
pas aussi bête que l'on croit mme ce
sont ces nous a fait des efforts pour
faire avancer les choses
alors même si il y a un besoin urgent de
renouveler les militants qui porte les
formations politiques on a quand même vu
certaines formations ici au plan local
se contenter d'un petit communiqué de
presse quelques jours avant la tenue du
scrutin pour dire pensez à vous rendre
aux urnes ne laissez pas la pensée a
glissé l'enveloppent dans l'urne parce
qu'il ne faut pas s'abstenir lors de ce
scrutin c'est suffisant ça
bon déjà suffisant mais non ce n'est pas
suffisant mais aussi on parle pas
d'europe
écoutez j'ai fait cinq ans j j'étais
très présent sur sur des médias et c'est
une chose qui est vrai pourquoi
simplement parce que l'europe nous avons
des possibilités dès que je ne va pas
c'est la faute de l'europe alors que
l'europe est dans notre quotidien mais
et là on nous sommes probablement il ya
eu des fonds européens sont les ids à
nantes qui vote au parlement de mx ce
sont d'abord des citoyens qui parce que
souvent on dit ah ouais l'europe décidé
qu'on subit non ce sont des
représentants désignés par le peuple qui
vont siéger à bruxelles et qui prennent
des décisions
oui tout à fait mais les décisions qui
sont prises ne soient pas forcément de
mauvaises décisions parce que vous avez
qu'on n'avait pas de majorité il faut il
faut il faut il faut trouver des
solutions il faut combiner il faut avoir
des ne pas aller dans la compromission
mais c'est comme ça on est en zone comme
on s y reprendre façonné par le français
renault parlerai au prix il n'y aura
jamais de majorité
moi seul parce que c'est ça qui est
difficile à entendre louis joseph
manscour on a voté au niveau national
français maintenant il y as deuxième
tour qui va consister à trouver des
alliances et s'entendre sur certains
grands axes pour la compte de la
continuité lac ou la construction de
l'europe
oui mais enfin qu'à écouter et que je
voulais vous nous sommes en démocratie
on avait on n'a qu'à demander à tous les
états membres à tous les acteurs de tous
les états membres de voter soit à pépé à
le voter ce matin se sont dits j'ai voté
hier j'ai voté avant-hier et voilà mon
quotidien va changer brusquement il a
tout faux leur nom le quotidien va pas
changer je pense que l'europe fait
beaucoup notamment pour les outre-mer on
n'a pas à s'en plaindre même si cette
europe qui est que celle ci n'est pas
celle à laquelle je voudrais souscrire
mois fait n'empêche que yann réalité
c'est que il faudra travailler ensemble
et surtout les autres mais pour faire
danser des choses alors vous allez tirer
votre révérence le 2 juillet prochain
louis joseph manscour content de
terminer sur cette note
de mandat européen oui j'ai fait une
belle carrière politique mais c'est pas
ce qui est important la justice quand
même de voir la situation dans laquelle
se trouve en ce moment notamment mon
parti le parti auquel j'appartiens
depuis 40 ans et quand même car on fait
beaucoup de choses pour pour la france
mais aussi pour les outre-mer et
j'espère que à des combats à mener en
tout cas en ce qui me concerne
bon je rentre mais je reste un militant
et si je peux apporter ma contribution
pour faire en sorte que le parti tout au
niveau national au parti local puis soit
parti je le ferai ce sera votre objectif
donc renforcé remettre sur pied le parti
socialiste en martinique au nombre a pas
je n'ai pas cette prétention mais
j'approuve entièrement expérience ma
petite contribution tout petit parce que
j'ai envie de faire autre chose aussi
merci louis joseph manscour d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin au lendemain de ce
scrutin européen rappelle que vous êtes
député européen en poste encore jusqu'au
2 juillet merci bonne journée
merci
[Musique]